Baltimore is on the cusp of a proud
renewal now is the time we must change
to grow it seems hard to believe but
months ago Baltimore's politicians were
confidently predicting an economic
revival for the city the crisis has put
police brutality in the spotlight left
leaders grasping for answers you got to
be present in the middle of the pain man
and even set families against themselves
we spoke with Neill Franklin of Law
Enforcement Against Prohibition he's a
34 year veteran of Maryland law
enforcement a former drug warrior who's
changed his perspective after the murder
of a colleague to find some answers to
charm city's deepest problems hi I'm
Todd crane in for reason TV we're here
with Neill Franklin of leap Law
Enforcement Against Prohibition thanks
for having me Todd so we've been
watching on the news a lot of what's
happening in Baltimore the riots and
that all the troubles going on there and
I'm wondering how do you feel that the
drug war plays into what we're seeing we
are still attempting to arrest our way
out of a public health problem you know
and in doing that they're making drug
arrests for whatever and as they look
for people who are either selling or
possessing drugs making those arrest
first of all those people are not
getting the attention that they need
which are health services but in
addition as we come through the city
certain parts of the city with this
dragnet we're scooping up people who
aren't even in the drug game we're just
arresting people we're stopping people
violating their Fourth Amendment rights
we're searching them in the middle of
the street and many of these people are
young people and when the uprising
kicked off a week ago it was the young
people who had had enough who had gotten
out of school went up to mondawmin mall
saw the line of police and their
frustrations were just emptied out on
that line of police so you've been in
law enforcement for over three decades
you've even run anti drug task forces in
the state of Maryland presumably you
were for a
long time a real believer in the drug
war what changed when I retired from the
Maryland State Police good friend of my
head totally was working undercover here
in the Washington DC area with the FBI
on a task force and he was buying
cocaine from a mid-level drug dealer and
he was killed by that drug dealer he was
shot at point-blank range and it was
that which started my I guess
questioning of the drug war as it
relates to violence by this time I'm
working for the Baltimore Police
Department as I had a training and then
around that time I went on to a website
and I found leaps new website Law
Enforcement Against Prohibition so I
continue researching and looking into
this problem so it was it was
recognizing the violence from
prohibition policies within our
communities that really got me moving in
this area of reform that's interesting
and also after the murder martin
O'Malley former governor of Maryland
went to visit the family of it totally
and very clearly it had a very different
effect on him than it did on you because
you've been very critical of a lot of
his policies and I'm curious what
policies of his have contributed to a
lot of the problems we're seeing in
baltimore today as with martin O'Malley
and other law enforcement folks at
newegg totally they vowed to go out and
push harder in making more arrest in
demonstrating that we're not going to
tolerate drug dealers anymore not really
looking deep into the problem and the
issue so with martin O'Malley started
this transition away from community
policing to zero tolerance policing when
Ned Norris left and went to another
agency martin O'Malley again goes to New
York and brings in another commander
whose career had been mostly about
narcotics enforcement while in New York
he immediately formed a 300-person unit
the organized crime division that would
focus strictly on low-level drug
enforcement one tenth of the department
pulling people men and women from the
district stations to form dish unit
renting cars so that we can put these
people into these cars on mark cars to
go out and make arrest after arrest
after arrest and before we knew it in
2005 we had 108,000 arrest in a city of
six hundred and twenty thousand
residents now some of those arrests were
of the same people over and over again
but I don't know of any other city in
this nation that had that type of arrest
ratio these zero-tolerance policies that
we put in place again it goes back to
the 108,000 arrest in 2005 how much
long-term damage did that do to these
neighborhoods in Baltimore to the
families in Baltimore to all these
people who now have an arrest record see
people think that you need a conviction
and have to do many years in prison for
that too negatively to affect your
employment and housing opportunities in
a negative way no you just need to
arrest you don't have to do time because
of Technology today any business owner
can search your name through these many
databases on a cell phone and find out
if you've been arrested and if you're in
competition for a job with six other
people and none of them have ever been
arrested what chance do you have a final
question based on what you've seen today
in our reaction to some of the riots is
there a long-term solution in place or
are these just more short-term patches
and we're going to see more of this in
the future I've seen no real long-term
plans in place again and I can speak to
Baltimore that's what I know I grew up
in Baltimore you know I was ahead of
training for the Baltimore Police
Department I'm still very much engaged
in that city and I've watched you know
administration after administration come
through that city and so I go back to
the martin O'Malley administration and
every one of his goals have always been
short term nothing ever was long term
and because he had these short-term
goals for instant results for whatever
with no long-term view he left it wide
open for long-term disaster and that so
that's what we're experiencing now with
the uprising in Baltimore people were
just tired and fed up with how the
police have been interacting with young
people in that city because of these
zero-tolerance policing programs that
that we've had and you say you just
wanted those short-term measures just to
make it to the next level yeah it's
quite evident i remember when i first
started speaking with him when I was
ahead of training I knew right away that
he wanted to be in the White House and
then you could see with every plan it
came down the road under his
administration it was short term just to
get some quick quick results some quick
numbers and it's all about numbers it
was all about numbers with him you know
whether it's an image of reducing crime
or we made this many arrest it was all
about numbers you know he had this one
number we're going to get the homicide
rate down to 175 per year no matter what
it takes we never met that but the
methods for attempting to do that were
disastrous to the city of Baltimore now
don't get me wrong there was some lives
saved because we got it down into the
200s there was some lives saved but
where are we today where are we going to
be tomorrow because of these short-term
goals and abandoning the community
policing piece here we got a lot of work
to do now and bringing police and
community together and I'm not sure how
we're going to be able to do that No
Neill Franklin thanks for talking to us
I appreciate it my pleasure I'm Todd
crane and for reason TV